you know I like to drink I like a tipple
but I also like to stay away from it too
i I've had too many wonderful friends
who really hurt themselves with alcohol
and I'd warned against that no I don't
think I think people creative people
think that their creativity and their
bohemian lifestyle gives them license to
be dysfunctional people it gives them
the freedom to drink too much and to be
bad at paying their bills and to shave
irregularly and paying your bills and
shaving regularly you know can have
their downside but I'll go and have a
real downside you um it doesn't give you
that license and it doesn't make you
more creative I I know people who have
been absolutely paralyzed by drink and
by other drugs it's you do get that
romantic guys like I want to be
Fitzgerald I want to be insane and I
want to be miserable you know when
you're young when you're young and
you're a writer you want to be miserable
you want to be that tragic figure you
know the genius taken too soon you want
to be the alcoholic the suicide these
are these are the real heroes of the
people who grind it out every day and
live to be a hundred you know who wants
to be e el doctorow you know he's a
wonderful writer but there's no romance
there but you want to be Hunter Thompson
but I don't think I think he all doctors
probably been a better Rider longer than
Hunter Thompson was you know a good
writer because he's had more normal
habits i'm not i'm not even like a
biggie el doctorow fan i just picked him
as a as a long-lived rider but you know
hunter thompson ooh boy there's not a
better political book than fear and
loathing on the campaign trail 72 and
there's not a funnier book than fear and
loathing in las vegas but I mean
anything he wrote in the past 30 years I
would
it was probably you know largely
unreadable I guess you could get through
it but you know that the spark isn't
there anymore and then I kind of got it
got killed in him and I think he
probably realized that too but you know
for 20 years there from the early 60s to
you know 1980 or so he was great i don't
i don't know if the drug spurred that
creativity I i think was all of a pot of
a piece he he was a crazy man and he
wrote like a crazy man and he lived like
a crazy man but i don't think the the
drugs made him the crazy writer that he
was drugs can certainly give you a new
perspective but generally they're
stultifying you know marijuana
stultifying LSD I guess fast anyone
you're 18 years old kind of a brain
killer you know I think you have to we
all have our adolescent fantasies and
you know I'm going to be this guy i'm
going to be Rimbaud and blah blah blah
but it's not the way to happiness in
life certainly but it's also it's not
the way to a great riding it generally
just gets in the way after you know what
I'm more a little bit more lyrical when
I'm hungover my poetry's got a is a
little fleeter but if I take a sip of
alcohol I can't write you know it kills
the sparking
you